[Music]
ashley is with us in August's georgia
hey Ashley how are you I'm great better
than I deserve what's up so a quick
question we are a single income family
my husband
Norah Terry we're on baby step two and
with the recent government shutdown and
the potential to have another government
shutdown soon what do you do when your
paycheck is being held hostage so to
speak at no fault of your own well let's
start with let's be realistic it was two
days
no no I'm absolutely totally understand
that but with the things they're saying
it could go into February 8th is there
used a line like way that covers our
first paycheck but if it were to go
further what what do you do if you don't
get your paycheck that you rely on
mm-hmm I'm just kind of asking for like
future reference yeah I got you I got
you okay number one I don't want to add
drama to it more than more than the
reality I don't want to make it a bigger
deal than it is because the number of
times that the military has not received
pay for any length in any long period of
time is almost zero it's just almost
never happened there's been several
times there's been government shutdowns
but there the truth is there's a lot
more political intrigue to it than
financial fact meaning it's a 48 hour or
72 hour I mean a long one is a week
that's a long one you know and I've been
through this several times in 30 years
sitting in this chair watching you guys
have to do this and I think it's a
dadgum shame that anybody messes with
you all you don't make that much money
anyway in the military you're serving
your country you're protecting all of us
and then they mess with you in Congress
they all ought to be smacked both sides
of the aisle so I get with you on all
that now having said that okay let's
let's just change the gears for a second
and let's say that you call me up and
you said hey my husband's the only one
working I'm at home working with the
kids aunt my husband's on
gun income and he works at a factory and
the factory might go on furlough or the
factory might have some layoffs do I do
something different with the emergency
fund the question I would ask you in
that case is okay what do you think the
probability is percentage if you think
it's greater than 5050 that you're gonna
have a hold and you probably ought to
stop your you stop your baby steps and
build up a little bit of an emergency
fund if you think the probability is
less than 50/50 he's gonna get laid off
over at the factory or there's gonna be
a furlough over at the factory then it's
just drama deal with it it's probably
not gonna happen it's just kind of one
of those unknown things and it gives you
all that much more reason to get out of
that and get your real emergency fund
build how much debt do you all have not
counting your house we don't have 20
thousand left on the car good okay and
what's your household income he makes
about fifty five years okay could sell a
car so we're actually looking into doing
that yeah because you know if I'm
looking at an unstable income situation
and I got one car in the car is the
whole problem that's an easy way to
clear it up and you know then start
saving towards a better car and get out
of that mess but aside from that the
answer is if you really believe no drama
allowed if you really believe actual
statistical probability that you're
gonna go without a check for X and
period of time anytime in the next six
months then you need to stop your
emergency fund if you think the
probability is greater than 50/50 you
need to stop all of your baby steps and
build your emergency fund if you think
the probability is greater than 50/50
that you're gonna go without a check
long enough that it's going to put your
family in jeopardy I got to tell you I
don't think that's there I think there's
a chance that February 8th you may have
another three-day hiccup or something
but these people are just playing
politics with each other and you're the
pawns on the board which makes me madder
than snot at them both of them but
anything you nah can do about it we just
have to watch these idiots be idiots
this is the Dave Ramsey show